bibliothèque schoelcher cathédrale de
fort de france château haut berry le
fleuron de l'architecturé martiniquaise
revisitée à travers le coup de crayon de
l'uqo c'est la deuxième fois que le
dessinateur consacre un album au
patrimoine de son île et ça a l'air de
plaire
il ya surtout une précision il a le sens
du détail de la perspective et puis
surtout il ya des planches avec des
points de vue différents temps en temps
on voit des photos aériennes la
troisième dimension for sale où il ya
beaucoup de recul dont il ya différentes
échelles et c'est vraiment inattendu et
donc c'est très vivant donner vie à ses
croquis une devise qui transparaissait
déjà dans l'univers de sa première bd le
zizi tata le lecteur découvre est déjà
dans chaque croquis le patrimoine
architectural de fort de france
dans ce nouvel ouvrage où la guadeloupe
et saint-pierre-et-miquelon ont une
place de choix
l'auteur s'inscrit dans une sorte de
quête identitaire
c'est un point de départ pour
s'identifier aussi à son pays et puis le
valoriser puisqu'il n'ya pas que la
plage et a pas que quelques même si à
musique il ya du patrimoine musical
aussi mais après que la plage et et la
nourriture qui sont intéressantes et il
ya aussi certains monuments
certains bateaux
bayonne enfin la 5,3 en guadeloupe etc
c'est important de connaître tout ça est
de valoriser et puis le se l'approprier
c'est toute une ville qui bat au rythme
de la bd dans chaque recoin abandonné
les murs deviennent des espaces
d'expression ça mais les deux graffeurs
reconnus la bande dessinée de thèmes
qu'il inspire comme moi aussi je suis
fan de bandes dessinées des mangas
donc ça m'a fait il ya plus qu'un
investissement personnel par rapport à
ce sujet la bande dessinée comme support
de l'animation de la ville nul doute que
ce concept trouve des adeptes
c'est une très bonne idée ça change de
ses murs grey ont peu délabré ça met de
la gaieté ça met de la couleur et ses
pouvoirs en avoir plus tant mieux ça
devient un petit peu a lieu nocturne
aussi où les gens se rencontrent on
reçoit des artistes la mairie nous a
même aidé de l'apprêter parfois les
vitrines pour pour présenter les oeuvres
des artistes qui viennent
j'espère qu'on va pouvoir être le
patrimoine de l'uqo présenter les rues
de la ville tels qu'ils avaient fait
déjà avec l'airé bâtiment les dents
creuses de la ville aux couleurs de la
bande dessinée une idée qui pourrait
faire son chemin mais il faudrait pour
cela qu'elle obtienne l'adhésion du plus
grand nombre
non